on ne l'a pas fait moi je le fais
magnifique
vous pouvez vous positionner sur merci
pour ça je n'aime pas mais aussi mais ça
fait plaisir à tout le monde où tout lui
écoute quand j'ai racheté par les
barrages c'est ma grande copine seconde
parler du travail
aimez vous arrivez trop bon dans ce que
j'ai bien se faire une petite
démonstration ça ne peut pas être mieux
multi on va profiter de vos caméras
parti pour un artiste côtoie beaucoup
ils sont partout
alors vous en pensez quoi
[Musique]
je suis passionné par le fascisme
quelque part d'accor j'ai bien dit le
fascisme le bénisse la différence la
différence est différent de mes
acheteurs un pénis en érection est un
phallus vous aimez faire un tennis
d'accord un pénis et pas forcément
l'érection faudrait avoir une élection
il sort tu nous lis beaucoup c'est pas
non c'est pas possible
vous êtes venu pour me voir
alors maintenant regardez moi
performance de monsieur book major tout
va se passer ici
n'oubliez pas être amusant fonds du ce a
pris
ça
[Musique]
c'est faux
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salon demo bas de pâtir des transports à
savigny si quelqu'un perd temps mais les
gens ont écouté ils sont français
toiture book major on va vous présenter
sa nouvelle oeuvre
[Musique]
je les appelais l'art de racisme
direction locale une gestion de la fuite
les deux
person des particuliers une oeuvre
mais qui a fait ça qui a fait ça mais
qui après ça vous savez combien de temps
j'ai passé pour la faire cette sculpture
de super phénix et café on a fait une
photo on n'a pas vu vous étiez jamais là
quand il faut
non c'est pas monsieur autant il est
tellement il était lourd
nous aimons excusez moi ce sont les
ajustements des bienfaits
juste mesure je me suis rapidement j'ai
vu l'enregistrement et je veux juste
besoin de savoir de vive voix qu'il a
fait parce que d'un point de vue légal
moi je peux rien faire avec les
enregistrements se mais il faut que la
payez vous expliquez moi je dois faire
qu'une seule chose que je dois faire si
je la met la police et un point de vue
les gagnent ils auront la possibilité de
régler le problème
j'arrive tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup des vibrations d'accord et que
du coup je recule c'est de ta faute
c'est une faute de déballage à tout
[ __ ] perçu apple qui fait pas appel
j'aime bien quand même que loïc
cellartis limites que tout le monde ce
qui l'exposé roland coucou mon volant
wii
dis moi je t'appelle gelli est ce qu'en
fait fuir les galeries et voulait
m'amener un vernissage est ce qu'on a
une amie en commun qui vous a parlé d'un
martin et sous ce que donnait donc
valérie volée prise en photo ont vécu
une statue qui voit les 40000 euros la
tata jusqu'à la conversation avec
l'avocat pardon et le juste juste une
indication c'est normal il n'y a pas de
stars ayant décroché supporter
renseignement
[Applaudissements]
comme ça tout va si mal images elles
sont là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi c'est moi j'ai rattrapé et moi c'est
moi je rattrape le truc en fait c'est
quelqu'un fût tombé moi je les rattrape
notre verbalement vraiment qu'il a fait
il faut avouer d'accord ok ok c'est
c'est mon ami qui a fait tomber deux
mois qui a fait tomber le bâton bloque
mais attendez c'est pas parfait extrait
du tout et du monde vivant vous avez
essayé de la rattraper
voyez pourquoi vous lille jennyfer la
basse qualité soutient que c'est une
pièce majeure d'un artiste non pas du
tout ce que vous êtes en train de
réinventer monsieur savard l'accès du
pic à 40 minutes ailleurs demandé au
moins un règlement excusez-moi de vous
interrompre mais il va demander au moins
règlement un minimum non mais parce que
c'est celle qui a fait tomber le truc
mais on va revoir on a partagé est ce
que c'est mon ami juste comme un groupe
se passe en afrique c'est du racket mais
pas du tout la casting donc son mélange
doit mériter ce sens je vais délaisser
200 avec vos est parfait non voilà juste
comme ça interrompt voisins
[Musique]
mais je vais voir ailleurs
on va te payer ni mal pour un type de
construction improbable poster à 40
milles
wen a fait tomber sans faire exprès j'ai
aussi une voiture et à ta faute tu vas
quand tu vois dans des notes en train de
dire que c'est le cas c'est moi qui les
fais tomber ni sétois nice et moi on va
dire que c'est tout les deux même si
c'est toi tu rigoles ou quoi c'est toi
qui me dit parce qu'on le sait passe
comme ça ma chérie tu es pas gilbert
montagné quand même tu rigole
franchement c'est dégueulasse que vous
avez fait non mais avait vu la toile et
non plus j'avais prévu un super cadeau
pour toi toi même temps on est en train
d'y soit de trouver avec géraldine
tyrannie se proposait de payer vingt
mille euros et salah ça ça vaut combien
gérald
[Applaudissements]
oui
mon scénario mais c'est une belle
[Applaudissements]